- I'm always ready.
- [Man] Stand by stage.
- [Announcer] Alright (mumbling)
Are you ready?
- [Audience] Yeah!
- [Announcer] That is not (mumbling).
Ladies and gentlemen, are you ready?
(audience clapping)
- What?
(mumbling)
What do you mean?
When I was gonna talk to them?
(mumbling)
Did you really think I
was gonna mess that up?
Just out of, just general curiosity,
you think I was gonna fumble that?
Just, no, no, but I mean just,
your gut intuition on me,
did you think I was fumbling that one?
- [Man] Yes.
- Okay, just wanted to make sure.
(laughing)
- [Announcer] The most
sought after live speaker
on the planet right now (mumbling)
Twitter and Tumblr and fewer.
He's been listed in (mumbling)
(audience cheering)
Gary Vaynerchuk!
(upbeat music)
- It's Gary Vee!
♪ You'll find me chasing the sun ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh ♪
- What's up, man?
Thank you.
What up?
(audience cheering)
Hey guys.
- [Announcer] It's Gary Vee!
- Let's do this.
Let's sit.
Let's sit, sit, sit.
- [Audience Member] I love you?
- I love you back.
What up Sydney?
(audience cheering)
Good afternoon, good evening.
Thank you so much for coming out.
A lot to cover in our time here together.
Couple things I wanna talk about.
First thing I wanna talk
about is the concept of
guilting people by giving
so much without expectation
that it creates the outcome
that you're looking for.
(clapping)
Thanks, Mom.
(audience laughing)
And I think it's an interesting thing,
because when I come to talks,
I'm always trying to
provide the most value
that I possibly can,
and I'm trying to find platforms
that connect all of us,
everybody in here is in a
different place in their journey,
whether it's entrepreneurship,
or working in environment, start up,
there's just so much different
shit happening in the room
that it's hard when you speak
because you don't wanna talk so narrow
that half the audience is checked out
'cause there's zero relevance.
And that's why I love
talking about attention
and I'll get to that in a minute
because the one thing I'm sure of
is that every single person
here needs to understand
that they have to grab attention
and then storytell and create
the action that they want.
On the same token, it is that
action that fascinates me.
Nobody's sitting here
without some sort of ambition
to create something to happen.
And I think there's a real huge
mistake and misunderstanding
or what, to be very frank, what I think
has gotten me here versus
other people in other statures
and different opportunities,
and there's just a very big difference
between branding and selling.
And I think for a lot of you in this room,
there's a real interesting conversation
because you want something to happen
and either A you can sell,
I think you guys know
what selling looks like.
(audience cheering)
Or you can brand and I'm
intrigued by branding
because branding's funny, right?
Branding, so many of you right now
are wearing clothes that you're wearing
not because Vans tagged you, right,
and cookied you or gave you
a special deal for one day,
it's because they built a
brand and you wanted to buy it,
and I would implore all of you,
and this is, for so many of you,
you have 10, 20, 30, 40,
50 years of your career
and you need to use that as leverage
because when you have time on your hands,
you can run a marathon instead of the 99%
of what I see everyday
which is everybody's
putting on their sprinting shoes
and trying to sell and close
on the first transaction,
which is just not an
effective longterm strategy.
It has value, it works, I get it.
I love selling stuff.
I love selling my new K-Swiss sneakers,
I love selling wine, I love
selling books, I like it.
But there's such a better way
if you're playing the long game.
And I think it's about bringing value.
The thing that I obsess about,
I mean I literally have
been reading, and I know,
'cause I see you guys see
me interacting with you,
I'm literally reading your
two tweets in the back room
and liking it, I'm engaging
and paying attention,
and trying to figure out how
am I going to bring value
to this specific audience,
this specific time,
in an environment where
I know a lot of you
have already watched plenty of my content.
Like how the fuck do you figure that out?
And it's intriguing to me
that as I go down the path of success,
I'm trying harder to bring
value, not the other way around.
And look, to me that is the framework.
To me the framework is
legacy not currency.
doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
To me the things that
are making the people
achieve going forward, and my friends,
why do you think all this stuff is
happening in Hollywood right now?
The truth is gonna be undefeated.
The internet is now the middle man,
for retail, for media, for our society.
That is the way it is now.
The internet is the middle man,
which means nobody's in
control except for the
end audience at scale.
You may sit here and dwell 'cause you're
a defensive minded person
and think somebody's controlling shit.
Facebook's not controlling shit.
Facebook's exposing you 'cause you're
the one liking that shit.
So we sit around and we
dwell and we go on defense
and we think and all this,
and what we need is
dramatic accountability.
You know how many people
in this audience right now
say that they're passionate
about too many things
and that's why they haven't done anything?
That's a fucking excuse to not do.
You're not too talented
in too many things,
you're fucking lazy.
(audience laughing)
And so I'm really intrigued
by a lot that's going on.
But the thing that I
know more than anything
is that we're living through
the single greatest era
for humans ever right now.
I know that we're
deploying plenty of things
that we're upset about,
and there's a lot of tension in the air,
and I think that's appropriate.
I just don't think that we
put things into context.
You may not be happy about certain things
and technology or politics
or business or what have you.
But that's a hell of a lot
better than the black plague.
And so to me.
(audience laughing)
It is.
Like I know shit sucks sometimes.
But remember Hitler?
(audience laughing)
So I'm extremely optimistic.
I'm extremely positive what's going on.
And it's all because of
the framework of this talk.
This thing.
You have to, how many people
do not have a cell phone?
Raise your hand.
Cool.
Zero, by the way, for
everybody in the front rows.
This thing is ridiculously powerful.
This thing is the remote
control of our society.
This thing has eliminated every excuse
out of your fucking mouth.
Because if you have to work 9:00 to 6:00
to pay the bills, to pay
your dues, to pay your debts,
that is exactly right and appropriate,
everybody comes from
different starting points.
I have unbelievable empathy to that.
The exciting thing, though,
is that our grandparents
didn't have this thing.
They had to work 9:00
to 6:00, 9:00 to 7:00,
and then there was only so much upside
that they could create
for themselves longterm,
from 7:00 to 2:00 in the morning.
This thing has fundamentally
changed everything.
And I just think we take it for granted.
I really wish everybody understood
the power that's literally
sitting in their hands right now.
This is literally a media creation
and distribution tool that would have cost
tens of millions of dollars
if you understand distribution.
The technology probably costs $20,000,
you know 25 years ago.
Cameras, this, that, fine.
The distribution?
You would have had to shoot
a satellite into space.
You would have had to
buy a printing press.
You would have had to buy trucks.
You would have had to done so much.
The fact that every person here
can literally turn this on themselves,
create content around something
they're interested in,
and then have platforms like
YouTube and Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter and LinkedIn distribute it,
let me remind you, at no cost,
is so batshit crazy for all
of us old fuckers in here,
that I just wish people would
not take it for granted.
And so my friends, I come here tonight
to really try to pull off one move.
Can I actually take somebody,
even if they're a huge fan,
or if they've never heard of me before,
and tweak their perspective
on what's actually going on?
Can I convince one of you that
nobody gives a shit about
your headaches and problems,
and when you complain,
you're just taking minutes off the board,
and energy off the board,
from doing something about it.
Literally I am fascinated by the
inability to be held accountable.
I am fascinated that you actually are
coming up and spending energy
and trying to say why
you're not successful
because you're older brother
did some shit in 1996.
And so (laughing) sorry.
I mean it's super interesting to me.
I read, and read, and read.
I don't watch, outside of
watching New York Jets football,
and now the Knicks are starting
to maybe try to do something,
so a little Knicks basketball,
like I consume nothing but your comments.
And I get into rabbit holes.
You know how on Wikipedia or YouTube,
you start off watching something
and then three hours later you're watching
like penguins shitting on each other?
(audience laughing)
That's what I do with comments.
You guys leave comments.
80% of it is either overwhelmingly like,
I'm the messiah, which
you can keep doing that.
It feels great.
Or I'm a snake oil
salesman and piece of shit,
I love that even more, by the way,
keep feeding me you fucking losers.
But the 20%'s super interesting to me.
Which is they'll say something,
and of that 20%, 10% say
something really intriguing.
I'm a little bit of an enigma.
I'm an interesting kind of character
in the way that I communicate
versus my actions.
Actually watch this.
How many people here.
Honest, remember lying is the devil.
How many people here honestly,
the first time or two
that they came across me,
thought I was a dick
face and didn't like me?
Raise your hands.
Raise 'em high.
Ooh, that's a little too many.
(audience laughing)
And so knowing that truth,
I am always fascinated because
I'm able to judge people
on how they react to me.
A lot of the people
that raised their hands
were in a mindset at the time
of not being comfortable being suffocated
from the excuse that
they were comfortable in.
If you ask me when I look at my content
and take myself out of it,
the thing that I'm doing
is I'm putting pressure.
I'm putting pressure,
and I'm using the truth
as my pressure point, which
is making me successful
and why so many people benefit from me.
Because once you can flip over
and once you can start actually
taking full accountability.
Like it's crazy, my parents,
you know it's funny,
when I talk about myself,
it's all about Sasha
and Tamara Vaynerchuk.
Like all the good shit's
that's happening with me,
I'm like I had nothing,
you know when you guys, you're the best.
I'm like, cool, my parents, you know,
being an immigrant,
like America capitalism,
I, if Misha and Zander crush
it, if VaynerMedia crushes it,
that I can be like, that's me.
But when I think about what my parents did
and what my circumstance
and environment did,
I'm just incapable of A
doing anything for anybody
and expecting anything in return.
You wanna have lived a very happy life?
Create the framework that I did naturally,
I don't know if I created
it or if it was given to me,
the greatest version
of life I've ever seen
is the one I'm living which is
nobody ever disappoints you because
you never expected anything from anybody.
I'm telling you right now,
you wanna talk about why so many of you
aren't exactly where you wanna be?
Look deep inside yourself and what
your expectations of others are.
And then the worst fuckers of you
are the ones that do shit
expecting something more in return.
That's my favorite.
That's like the 10 emails I got today.
"Gary Vee, I'll buy you
lunch when you're in Sydney."
Yeah, that sounds fucking rad, Rick.
(audience laughing)
Can't wait to get that $8.00 sandwich
for a fucking hour and half session.
My friends, accountability,
giving with no expectation in
return, playing the long game.
Every single person's business or ambition
will grow exponentially tomorrow
if they spend the next 13 years
giving away free content forever.
Seems super non natural.
When do you monetize?
How do you do this?
The person that holds the
breath the longest wins.
It's just very simple.
The problem is is there's
so many people here
that are just not patient, and you're not,
you know the youngsters aren't patient,
because they have chips on their shoulder
because they wanna prove to Mom and Dad
that they're right and
they're gonna do it their way,
and the second they start
doing their process,
they've got the pressure on them,
they haven't made it yet.
This is all about shortcuts
versus the long game.
I spent the first 13 years of my career
building my dad's liquor business for him.
I was 34 years old, had
no money to my name,
owned zero percent of Wine Library
and started VaynerMedia with AJ
by getting somebody to pay us $80,000
before we did the campaign,
'cause I had no dollars.
I decided to spend the
first 13 years of my life
working 15 hours a day
to build my dad's business for him,
because I felt so thankful for
what my parents did for me.
So when people say easy
for you or this and that,
I'm like, look at my narrative.
How many of you are not 34 years old?
Younger than 34?
Raise your hands.
All of you that just raised your hands,
I never made $100,000 a year,
think about how much
time you actually have.
I honed my skills, I learned
how to build a business.
But everybody's so impatient.
Lack of patience and entitlement
are the frameworks to why
people aren't successful here.
I'm talking very heavy shit off the gate,
because before I get to the examples
of what you should do on
Facebook and Instagram
and how influencer marketing's working,
and where the white space in our industry
and voice and Alexa
skills and all this shit
you know I'm gonna go into in a minute,
before I get there,
if your fucking mind isn't right,
it doesn't matter how you execute.
And for the people that
are over 45 and above,
over 45 and above?
If you're still trying to get yours,
you need to understand that the shit,
if you're not satisfied, if
you're not where you wanna be,
you need to understand that
you've had time now to play,
and the way you've been
playing it isn't working.
Just important to understand that.
Now if you're pumped and you're awesome,
then fucking, you won.
And by the way, this isn't a money game.
If you make $57,000 a year and have the
work life balance that you want,
you're happy as shit, you fucking won.
I know people making $8 million a year
and they're fucking miserable
and hate their fucking life.
And I have friends who make $67,000,
they're just loving life,
four softball teams,
and fucking love it.
This is not a dollars and cents shit,
I don't give a fuck how
much money you make.
Do you feel pumped as
fuck when you wake up?
Like I do.
I barely fucking sleep
on these kinda trips,
and I can't wait to get over here
and talk to you about it
because I fucking love it.
I love grinding,
I love all the fires I had
to put out in the greenroom,
I love that we lost an
$8 million pitch today.
I love it, I love it.
(audience clapping)
I mean it.
Because I don't want the stuff.
I don't want the stuff.
Everybody wants the fucking stuff.
You want the stuff 'cause
it's closing the gap
of insecurity or not happiness.
That's what you want.
You want nice shit so other
people think you're good
because you're not confident
within your own self.
Like when you start actually figuring out
how not to give a fuck about
anybody else's opinion for real,
and I'm talking about your
spouse, and your children,
and your parents, that deep,
let alone your fucking neighbor
or your homie from around the way,
shit gets really fucking quiet in here.
Shit gets real good in here.
And I am desperate to figure out why
you feel like you aren't in that place.
What is it?
Parenting, I get it, I know why,
I'm just trying to get you to realize
what are you waiting for to change.
The reason I talk randomly about going and
visiting retirement homes
is 'cause I want you to see
what regret and resentment
looks like at 90 years old.
The reason I think the number one thing
that every person in this room should do
is go and volunteer in a
retirement home next week for a day
is because A it's a nice
deed and they'll love it,
but you are going to get disproportionally
more value out of it.
Because you're gonna look at a stranger
who's not your grandparent,
and you're gonna jam.
You'll talk and you'll interact,
and I promise you, when
you see 90 year old
regret or resentment from not doing,
or living their lives by
somebody else's point of view,
aka their parents, you
will get so fucking scared
it will completely change the
course of how you do shit.
It stuns me that people's
self esteem in this room
are as wrapped up in how many
Instagram followers they have.
It stuns me in the shit that we do
because of other people's opinions.
The reason I've been
able to deploy patience
is 'cause when I was 29 years old
and worked for my daddy's liquor store,
and my other friends were at Wall Street
making $200,000 a year,
I didn't give a fuck.
I didn't give a fuck, because I knew
how it was gonna all end up.
I knew exactly who I was.
I laugh that you guys think
I'm doing something right now.
I haven't even fucking started.
I'm being dead fucking serious with you.
(audience clapping)
And so I've spent the
last two or three years
spending more time trying
to figure out what the fuck,
how did they build me like this,
what was the circumstance
that got me here,
and how the hell do I
pass on anything to you?
I realize the reason I give
away all my best stuff for free,
is because if you get some,
it's not gonna come out of my expense.
I love how many of you think
you've got some big idea
that you can't share with anybody
and you want people to sign NDAs.
What the fuck's the matter with you?
Ideas are completely a commodity.
I'll give you every idea of every
business that's gonna work.
I'll give you a thousand of them.
In eSports, in AI and
and machine learning,
and blockchain, and crypto,
and I'll go on and on,
I'll give you everything.
I'll give you every single thing.
The problem is ideas are like
knowing you should do pushups.
(audience laughing)
Knowing you should do pushups
versus doing pushups
is a very big difference.
I am always talking about
hustle and hard work
and people like to razz
me, too much, too much.
The only reason I talk about that is
it's not interesting for me to sit here
and tell you to become smarter.
Imagine if this talk was like,
"Hey guys, be smarter."
There's zero practicality in that.
The one guaranteed controllable thing
for this entire audience, row by row,
is if you work more, more could happen.
If you work, I love when people are like,
"Hey Gary, but,"
you know, they raise their hand and they,
"Hey Gary, listen you
talk about working hard.
"But I'm working smart.
"And that's working."
And I'm like, cool, bro,
but I'm working hard
and smart, so fuck you.
(audience laughing)
Guys, we are living through a
ridiculously phenomenal era.
And let me explain what it is.
It's called the Facebook era.
First point of advice, if you do not spend
an ungodly amount of your time and energy
on Facebook and Instagram,
regardless of what you do,
I'm talking you're
targeting 50 to 80 year olds
in a B2B environment, so I'm
gonna say this nice and slow,
I'm a business man, not
a social media guru,
listen very carefully.
If you are not spending a
disproportionate amount,
your money, and time, and energy in 2018
on Facebook and Instagram, you are leaving
significant upside for what you're trying
to achieve on the table.
This ship has sailed.
This is not a debatable issue anymore.
And when I look at the prices
for the Australian market
of attention, it's even
better than the U.S. market.
When I look at the Australian influencers,
what they're asking for for shout outs
in compared to the U.S. market,
even though they're getting
more organic reach, not
less, it's not even funny.
How many people here
sell a physical product?
Raise your hands.
All of you that are be
deeply become practitioners,
in what Instagram influencers
marketplace looks like.
How much does it cost to
have somebody on Instagram
with a following shout out your product?
Whether she or he has
3,000 fans or 1.9 million,
there is an arbitrage
because people don't know
how to price themselves.
Some are asking for too much.
Some are asking for too little.
But it's an inefficient marketplace
that you could take advantage of
because I don't know if you guys heard,
but people are fucking
living on this device.
Literally, literally, I almost
had a heart attack in the greenroom,
because I was in the greenroom,
I went to go take a piss,
I put my phone down,
and it started sliding.
(audience laughing)
My life flashed before my eyes.
The thought that this
would go into the toilet
and I would not be able to have a phone
for a day and a half, blew
my fucking face off my body.
(audience laughing)
this is the single most
important literally
I have a wallet on me, and fuck,
I would literally rather
somebody come up here
shoot me with a gun and steal my passport
than lose my phone.
(audience laughing)
Why is that?
It's because the world runs through this.
Now you may think that's sad
because you grew up pre-cell phone.
You might think that's sad
because you reminisce of
the days you had a pager
and that was super cool.
(audience laughing)
You may think that's sad
'cause you don't like
the kids being on it too much,
or when you go out to
dinner, it's not nice
that the couple's sitting
there and both on the phone,
and that's not the way it should
be according to you, Sally.
(audience laughing)
But technology and society
doesn't give a shit
about how you think it should be.
It just does what it does.
And it is your job to adjust
to the reality of the situation.
And the reality of the situation is
if you do not know how
to make written words,
pictures, or video, or audio sound
for the phone that we all hold in our hand
across the 10 platforms called
Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat,
YouTube, LinkedIn, blah, blah, blah,
you are irrelevant.
Let me make this perfectly clear.
If you think Google AdWords and email
and direct mail and
events and everything else
are gonna get you to the
next chapter, you will lose.
All those things I mentioned work.
They're just either priced appropriately
or grossly overpriced,
while the things I just
talked about prior to that
are grossly under priced.
If you pay the appropriate
price for Google
and direct mail, and your competitor
under buys attention on
Facebook and Instagram,
you will lose.
That is how it's always happened.
If you're baffled how the
biggest companies in the world
continue to go out of business,
it's because of the thing
that I just talked about.
Now let me tell you what's gonna happen
over the next five years.
Because of VaynerMedia, and this is why
I strategically did it,
for many other reasons,
we work with Budweiser and Pepsi and GE
and the biggest companies in the world.
None of these companies are remotely close
spending enough money on Facebook.
Not even close.
When they wake up, like they
did on Google in 2009 and 10,
even though I was buying attention
2001, two, three, four, five,
when they wake up, which they're
about two years away from waking up
and they start pouring
the right amount of money
into those platforms, you will no longer
be paying $6.00 CPMs in front
of any citizen in Australia
that you want targeted to
Asian, or African American,
or a footie fan, or
somebody who drinks beer,
or who likes Hunter Valley Sémillon,
or all the other things
that you can do on Facebook,
yet you don't know this because
you guys aren't practitioners.
You have opinions on Facebook advertising,
you just have never run
any Facebook fucking ads.
When that happens in 24 months,
and they start spending the right money,
you're not gonna have enough
money to reach the people.
Nobody here's running to the TV station
to run tons of television commercials,
'cause they're too expensive for you.
And that's what's going to
happen on Facebook and Instagram,
and you're gonna think back to this talk
and be really fucking pissed
that you were super fired
up when Gary Vee came,
but a week later you went back
to the same bullshit habits
that got you there in the first place.
And I am putting pressure
on this conversation
with the deep hope, the passion,
that you have the humility
to start actually doing the work required
to achieve the shit that's
coming out of your mouth.
I am fascinated by how many people here
are gonna build a million dollar business
and aren't putting in enough work
or enough research and smarts
to get even close to that place.
While we have the greatest era ever.
Let me explain.
If this was a business talk in 1974
and I was telling you stuff,
you'd have to go to the
library to read fucking books.
To get more detailed
information when I was done.
The fact that everybody
here who has no fucking idea
how to make a Snapchat filter
or run a YouTube pre-roll on a video
based on the queries and searches
that person made on Google
or how to do targeted Facebook
RSVP event advertising
that is grossly under priced.
Or how to price or even begin to price
an Instagram influencer that's
asking for an amount of money.
The fact that you guys have,
and you might wanna write this down,
this incredible resource for free,
G-O-O-G-L-E.com
The fact that you have that,
watching people write this
down is making me laugh.
(audience laughing)
The fact that you have
Google, and you can type in
how do I price Instagram
influencers, enter,
and 33 minutes later be
somewhat decently educated
on what to do and yet
everybody's throwing up
their hands and saying,
Gary, I don't get all this shit.
You didn't get driving,
you figured it out.
We are in a place where we
are not putting in the work.
We are in a place where
we are not accepting
the gravitas of the situation,
which is I'm gonna say it again,
the single greatest era
to be an entrepreneur
because the internet is now at scale.
Guys, when I started selling
wine on the internet in 1997
most people didn't have a computer
let alone be on the internet.
I would literally go to things and be like
you wanna buy some wine on the internet,
or actually I didn't call it the internet.
You wanna buy some wine on
the information super highway?
(audience laughing)
People didn't even know.
I would ask for people's email addresses
and they didn't even, like,
it would be like if I'm
talking to you right now
about VR infrastructure, or
the way that a lot of you
don't understand the
blockchain or Ethereum,
and you try to talk about
bitcoin like you know something,
and you have no idea what
you're talking about, right?
Like that.
That's how the internet was in 97.
The fact that all of us
are now in a place where
this entire room has a cell phone device,
internet access, and has
one to three of these apps
downloaded and that you can
produce on that platform
and it costs you, let me
say it again, nothing,
and you can speak about
Facebook ads, cool,
but you could still go organic.
You could.
It's why you should
really focus on Instagram
because 30, 40% organic for now,
is a hell of lot
interesting, in my opinion.
Especially when you get
to become a practitioner,
and you start putting 15 hashtags
around your industry and your product
and you have people discover you for,
let's say it one more time, free, yet
we do not have the humility
to put in the work.
It baffles my mind that
you've not spent 100 hours
in research on Snapchat, LinkedIn,
Facebook, and Instagram marketing.
You think you're gonna outsource
it to your 13 old niece.
You think it's not gonna matter.
You think a new app's gonna come along.
That's fine.
But I'm gonna tell you right now,
the regret in this room
to not going all in
on those platforms during this era
is going to be quite
high in four, five years,
when everybody realizes
what we just lived through.
I have enormous regret.
My only business regret
in my career is that I
did not spend enough money on Google
during 2002 to 2005 when I was
building my dad's liquor store,
because I had words for five cents a clip,
and I didn't understand
how good of a deal it was.
Words that I spent ten cents a click for
are now $8.00, $6.00, $4.00.
It changed.
It came and went.
I built a big business for
my dad on the back of it,
but it could have been much bigger.
You might be doing a little Facebook
and a little bit of Instagram,
but you're not doing enough.
It is under priced.
And by the way, this
whole ten minute rant,
just so everybody knows,
I don't give a fuck if you
do anything I just said.
I'm putting this on film to
just be historically correct.
(audience laughing)
You're not my sister.
I don't care.
And so I implore you,
I've got nothing to fucking
sell you girls and boys.
I'm trying to sell
legacy here and be right.
So please figure out why you're not
doing what I just said,
and usually it comes from
hard core human flaws.
Audacity.
Ego.
Just don't wanna do the work.
You know, you've been
working hard on other things.
You don't wanna do the work.
You don't have time.
My friends, way bigger
companies than yours
are about to go out of business
over the next five years
because they're underestimating this.
I just want everybody here,
way bigger companies than yours
are about to go out of business,
and are going out of business.
In America Toys R Us has
gone out of business,
there's news companies in this
country going out of business.
There's real shit going on.
You haven't seen anything yet.
I wanna remind you that 13 years ago,
everything we just talked
about doesn't exist.
Not the fucking iPhone, not
Facebook, not YouTube, nothing.
This has happened in 12 years, you know?
And for us that are 40, 42 and older.
That's like yesterday.
I understand if you're 19,
that seems like a long time.
It won't soon.
And in 10 years, everything that we're
talking about now is bullshit.
This iPhone X that's supposed
to be so fucking rad,
this is literally a piece
of dooky in 10 years.
Where do you think we're going?
What do you think's gonna
happen with machine learning
and AI and crypto?
Where do you think this is all going?
So if you haven't fully immersed yourself
into a hard core digital world,
that's like you not
running on the treadmill
leading up to the longest
marathon of your life.
What do you think it's gonna go backwards?
What do you think they're
gonna shut down the internet?
(audience laughing)
We're gonna all write letters,
it's gonna be really fucking sweet?
(audience laughing)
Where do you think the world's going?
And so please, I beg
you to take this talk,
this moment, this night
to have the cold shower
that I'm trying to deliver
to recognize you're not doing enough.
You're not pushing it hard enough,
you're not educated enough,
you're not doing the hard work.
You're just not.
I know it.
I know it, and again, listen,
I'm sure there's plenty of you
doing all the right things,
cool (clapping)
I'm talking about the fact
that I looked at everybody
who used this hashtag today
and then spent time on my
flight from Brisbane here
and in the back room looking
at what you're doing,
you're mailing it in.
You've got the accounts
to make yourself feel
good that you're doing it.
What's the ROI of a piano?
For me,
dick.
(audience laughing)
For Elton John, a billion dollars.
How many people here,
this is time to tell the truth
'cause it's okay, 'cause a
lot of hands should go up.
How many people here have run Facebook ads
that didn't work for them?
Raise your hands.
Raise them high, and I wanna, stand up.
Stand up if you ran Facebook ads
and it didn't work for you.
I want everybody to look around.
In my passionate plea
for the last 15 minutes,
and then in the people that stood up here,
you guys can sit down, thank you so much,
is the rub,
is the thing that I'm
most passionate about.
How many people here have run Facebook ads
that have worked for them, stand up.
This is it.
This is the thing that matters to me.
Thank you, you can sit down.
So many things can work,
but you have to be good at it.
but you have to try more.
So many people ran Facebook
ads in that first group,
spent a couple thousand bucks,
maybe even tens of thousands
of dollars, it didn't work,
and they decided that that
was enough information
to deem the whole thing not working.
We are making short term mistakes.
We are not investing in the
reality of understanding
the only thing that matters,
which is the end consumer's attention.
Where your attention is is where I am.
Why did I start getting serious
about my podcast in December of last year?
Here's why.
How many people here consume my content?
Raise your hand.
Thank you.
Of those people, how many in the last year
have started listening to my podcast
or listened to my podcast?
Raise your hand.
Thank you.
How many in the last year
have started listening
more to the podcast and
consuming less of the video?
Raise your hand.
Stand up.
I really appreciate
you coming up and down,
I appreciate it, thank you.
I want people to see.
Look around, these are people who in 2017
started listening to radio more
than watching television.
These are people who've
been listening more
to my podcast than watching video.
Sit down, thank you so much.
Because these are people
who value their time so much
that they subconsciously figured out
that they could get the
information but they could be doing
something else in parallel
while they're listening to the information
so that they could do
two things instead of one
because we continue to grossly
underestimate our capability.
My friends, texting and
driving, super dangerous, right?
Plenty of, more people die from
that than we report, right?
But you know how many people
should die from texting and driving?
Everyone.
It is super hard core that
you're not looking at the road
and you're looking at a phone.
The reality is is that humans
can do multiple things at once.
We grossly underestimate us.
We're about to live in
the growing era of voice.
Get ready for the next
five to seven years,
all of the action, all
of this unbelievable
under priced attention, is
coming to a voice next to you.
It's going to be in
podcast form right now.
Over next half decade,
between Amazon, Alexa,
and Google Home, and Apple Home Pod,
and Facebook better fucking figure it out,
and whoever else is playing,
they're gonna produce things,
and every single person here is gonna be
brushing their teeth seven years from now
out of toothpaste,
they're gonna spit it and
they're gonna say something like,
"Alexa, reorder my
toothpaste," and it will.
Alexa don't forget to bring
Mary an anniversary present tomorrow.
Do you want me to buy
the anniversary present?
Sure.
Cool.
Lack of friction.
Every person here gives
away everything for speed.
You overpay, you give money for speed,
you give up your privacy for speed,
you guys put your social security numbers,
credit cards, addresses, everything,
just so that your phone won't ask you
for the password again.
We're living through the biggest shift
in human culture since the printing press
became a media source that
dictated our thoughts.
This is a big deal.
This isn't a what's a marketing campaign
I can come up with, or what's
an app that's gonna be next,
Gary, so I can be on it?
This is a it's happening
right in your fucking face
and you're not doing anything about it.
So look, you could get fired up,
you could take courses,
you can read books,
you can do anything you want.
I implore you to do none of that.
And start actually doing.
Nothing would make me happier
than if every person in this room
would stop watching my content
and spent their time testing and learning
the theories that I've shoved
down your fucking throat
for the last two years.
Because the only way shit's
gonna happen is if you do.
And you can sit around and ponder
and debate and tell me why no,
or why it's bad, or this and that.
All you're doing is layering
excuse on top of excuse
to not doing the thing you don't wanna do
which is go learn something for 48 hours
or 97 hours or 400 hours,
and then go work 15 hours
a day to achieve the shit
that's coming out of your mouth.
Period, end of story.
And what makes me sad is
unlike 1984 and 1992 and 1967,
if you actually did what
I'm telling you to do,
you would get disproportionate dollars,
disproportionate impact,
and disproportionate growth
in a shorter period of time
than any generation prior
to us from this day back.
Greatest era ever, most entitlement ever.
Greatest era ever, most excuses ever.
And that's what we're living through.
And there's a couple people who
are doing something about it
and a lot of good things
are happening for them.
So, look, I think it's hardcore for me.
Like, I'm sitting here and I'm like fuck,
how the fuck do I just
get them to do this.
How do I get them to understand
how ridiculous it is?
Watch what I do, not what I say.
There's a reason I didn't
put out a lot of content
in 2012, 13, 14.
It's 'cause there was nothing
remotely this interesting.
Facebook was still growing
in its product and its scale.
Twitter wasn't an effective
selling mechanism.
It was a great community builder
and for branding, incredible,
I wanna remind you that's how I go here.
Right?
And we weren't there yet.
Frictionless payment, this and that.
We just weren't there yet.
The reason I've gotten so loud
and traveling over the world
two times over in a fucking week
is 'cause I'm desperate to put it on film
and be historically correct, I'm desperate
for one of you to email
me three years from now
and say, "You know what?
"It was the Sydney talk that finally got
"me outta my bullshit and I got educated
"and I went hard on LinkedIn
following your model."
That's what I'm looking for.
And so please, one, two, three of you,
because that's where I'm at.
Been doing this a long time.
Everybody's sitting there saying,
"Yeah, this is it, I'm gonna do it."
And then next Thursday
happens and you lose a client
and you go on defense.
So please be that person
that fulfills the strategy
that I'm deploying here.
Couple of things.
How many people here have employees?
Raise your hand.
Great.
Let's talk about a couple random things
as little footnotes on the way out.
Hiring.
How many people here struggle with hiring?
Good.
It's wrapped up in your ego.
It's not about hiring, it's about firing.
Too many people, how many
people struggle with hiring?
Me too, included, one more time.
Too many of you don't wanna admit
that you've made the wrong hire
so you hold on to somebody
that it's black and white
that you should be firing
but you don't wanna do it 'cause your ego
is wrapped up because
you're a good hirerer
and you are gonna figure
it out and fix it.
It's the most interesting
psychology in business
that I've seen, I'm fascinated by it,
and it's why I wanted
to throw it out here.
It's not about being great at hiring,
it's about being great at firing.
Number two, if you
aren't firing the person
that's making the most money for you
but they're the biggest
piece of shit and suck
for the other boys and girls,
you will long term lose.
If you are holding on to somebody
who's straight fucking cancer
but they're delivering on
the field, you will lose.
Look at every sports team in history.
When there isn't
continuity and good vibes,
no matter how much talent that
team has, they fucking lose.
Wonder why?
'Cause it's the way it's played.
It's how humans work.
No one person matters enough,
have the bravery to
get rid of that person,
because it is hurting
your longterm upside.
Most of you don't wanna do that
because that means you have to go back in
and do something that
person's covering and
you deserve to lose and
your company will lose.
So those are my two things on hiring.
Real quick, while I've got you.
This millennial talk is such horseshit,
it pisses me the fuck off.
Listening to all you old fuckers
claim that millennials
are entitled and lazy
is so fucking boring and so sad
and shows how big of a
fucking loser you are,
it's incredible.
You're gonna tell me, how
many people are 40 and older?
Raise your hands.
You're gonna tell me
you didn't have a bunch
of lazy fuckers around
you back in the day?
(audience laughing)
It is ridiculous and it
is a terrible mindset,
and it's absolutely
hurting so many of you,
'cause you're disrespecting technology
and the reality of the game.
This is the greatest generation,
there are much better human
beings as a whole than we are,
sure some of 'em suck,
'cause some of suck in every generation.
Yes, do a lot of 'em have
an entitlement issue?
Absolutely.
It's not their fault.
The world's been good for too long.
Super easy to complain about
not getting a whole lotta likes
when people aren't going
to war and getting killed.
So you can't be mad at them
because the world got
good for a long time.
We've lost perspective.
I also wanna remind most
of the 40 year olders,
we're the ones that created these kids.
Everybody protecting
little Sal from not losing,
made him a fucking loser.
(audience laughing)
Eight place trophies don't win.
(audience clapping)
How many people have
more than 20 employees?
Raise your hand.
Little fun fact, super interesting to me,
something that's really helped me,
just trying to throw some
random shit out here,
I hope you're in the mindset
that you work for them,
not the other way around.
The number one thing
that has worked for me
is I genuinely believe
I work for everybody
that works for me.
I work for them.
It is the only mindset, it's
what I started this talk with.
My fault, my this, right?
This $8 million pitch we lost today,
I didn't touch it at all.
My people did.
I hear the news I'm like I fucked up.
Didn't make the deck,
didn't go to the meeting,
was not part of anything,
I fucked up because I hired those people.
I'm the last line of defense.
It's me.
Another thing that
always blew my mind about
my dad and other people that I watch,
they expect their employees
to work as hard as them.
Makes me laugh.
How the fuck do you expect
somebody to work as hard as you
when you own the thing?
If you want your employees
to work as hard as you,
give them equal equity to what you have.
A miraculous thing will happen.
They'll start working as hard as you.
I have a funny feeling that's
not the trade that you wanna make.
So become far more realistic
about your expectations
and look at what your compensating.
And then on compensation.
If you're lucky, and next
year, I have 800 employees,
next year I will mandate
spending 15 minutes
with every one of my
employees every six months.
It is gonna eat up and
ungodly amount of my time.
My entire mission in that time
is to get to know who they
are a little bit more,
get them a little more
comfortable to tell me the truth
because we have an actual relationship,
and build context on what drives them.
Because there's plenty
people who want money.
There's plenty people
who want a bigger title,
work, life balance, travel,
I actually don't care.
I just need to know what they are.
If you're unbelievable,
you can have 'em all.
If you kinda suck, you're
gonna have to pick one.
But the reality is is
I need to put them in a
position to tell me what it is,
and I'm quadrupling down on
the context with my employees.
Way too many of us spend
way too much energy
on customers and nowhere
close to enough on employees.
And I promise you, if you reverse that,
your organizations will
feel the financial impact
in a very significant way.
Gentleman who introduced
me said something to me,
today, this morning in
Brisbane I said, you know,
everything I'm trying to do here
is predicated on trying to figure out
what people are saying behind my back.
And he said to me that,
"You know, it's a real pleasure
to have you here, Gary.
"I've gotta tell you, it's
interesting, I do this a lot,
"you do this a lot, it's super interesting
"how people talk about you
back here in the set up room
"and how many nice things
are said about you."
My friends, everybody's watching.
And now with technology,
everybody's watching for real.
Every word, every tweet,
every Facebook thing you say,
is something that you're gonna
have to explain to your grandchild.
Everything you sell, how you
sell it, how you interact.
I implore you, listen, it's one thing
when somebody leaves an
anonymous review on our site
and says I'm a jerk because
they got fired and they sucked.
Fine.
It's another thing if
somebody has never met me
and I said that their company sucks
and they get upset and
they say I'm a blowhard.
Makes sense.
But the people that
actually interact with you,
who spend time with you,
you better make sure
that you're living a life
that puts you in a position for
them to say the right thing.
The only way you can do that,
actually, in my opinion,
is to have very longterm vision.
So many people here wanna
it to happen tomorrow.
And they're gonna live
for another 77 years.
So many of you are
taking shortcuts to make
an extra $15,000 tomorrow,
and it's gonna cost you
money for the next 44 years.
We are stunningly intriguing animals
with our inability to be patient.
With our desperate need to get
something in the short term
only to prove something to everybody else
because we haven't proved it to ourselves.
Please, please, please,
stop playing that game,
because it is binary.
The ones that play that
game are unhappy and lose.
The ones that don't, are happy and win.
It's crystal clear, historic.
This has nothing to do with this.
This shit's been around since cavemen
hit each other with a fucking club.
Please do the right thing.
It always is the right thing.
And that doesn't mean
just being (spitting)
noble and everything I just talked about.
It means putting in the work
both educating yourself on
the shit that's actually happening,
and then doing the output of the work,
to actually achieve the audacity
that is coming out of your mouth
that you're gonna live one
of the best lives on earth.
I remind you how few people,
everybody's an entrepreneur
now on Instagram.
How many people are gonna
be successful entrepreneurs
is a different game.
I could change my bio on my
Instagram account right now
real easy to say rapper.
(audience laughing)
I want to.
But am I gonna make it?
I'll leave you with that.
Do you have self awareness?
Do you know who you actually are versus
who you wish you were?
Because a lot of you are playing
based on what you wish you were.
The second you figure
out who the fuck you are
and don't apologize for
it and surround yourself
with the people that do the
things that you can't do,
whether they're your
partner or you pay them,
a lot of good shit will happen.
And so, self awareness
and humility and empathy
and all these warm and fuzzy
things that grandma talks about
happen to be the biggest secrets
in the rough and tumble game of business.
I highly recommend you get
in touch with those emotions.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentlemen, Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience clapping)
- Thanks guys, thanks for having me.
- [Announcer] Let him hear you, Sydney.
Give it up for Gary.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
Let me make a little content here,
I haven't done this in a long time.
Alright now really lose
your fucking minds.
Here we go,
go!
Go crazy!
(audience cheering)
(laughing)
Love you guys.
Thank you.
- [Announcer] Great job.
Give Gary one more big hand, guys.
Give it up.
(audience clapping)
You're gonna post it right there?
(laughing)
Give Gary another hand, guys.
Yes, good stuff.
Give him a hand.
(mellow music)